hey everybody welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i'm one of your hosts reza
haslam and i'm your other host reid
wilson hey rayne how's it going today
pretty good russell how are you i'm
doing very well you know i'm so glad to
be doing this with you oh every day that
i get to host this podcast with you is a
great day
yes yes there's there's a video
component on here people can see that
it's you're not really rain oh [ __ ] i
forgot about the video
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
all right uh folks uh my co-host rayne
wilson is not here he is currently
traveling the world on peacock's dime
going around quote-unquote in search of
happiness that's a real
job
that they give
celebrities
in hollywood they actually
will pay you
to go around the world
and
search for
happiness that's a legit job you dig
ditches
rain travels the world in first class
and and looks for for happiness which is
why i'm here by myself
on the metaphysical milkshake pod
uh this is what it would sound like if
this were just hosted by me and no one
else and
and since it is hosted by me i get to
just invite whoever the hell i want to
on this show and today i get to bring on
one of my dear dear friends
joel stein who wants to talk
about a subject that is very close to my
heart and that is
the the subject of anti-intellectualism
or as we put it on the show
what's so bad about being smart
i mean
i feel like
you know i worked very hard i i have a
lot of degrees i'm not saying that
degrees necessarily make you a smarter
person no no they do no never mind
that's exactly what i'm saying yes yes
education
and
the the fruits of that education make
you a smarter person does it make you a
better person obviously not obviously
not but that's not what we're talking
about we're not talking about morality
here
we're not talking about
you know
value but but we are talking about the
fact that
you know there are people who have spent
their lives
studying certain topics certain issues
from a lot of different vantage points
with the hope that they could actually
do some good in the world with the
knowledge that they have gained and i
don't need to tell you
that uh listen we live in a country
right now that
has
a very
dangerous uh
anti-intellectual
anti-knowledge anti-education
uh string to it
uh this is something that i've you know
discovered in my own personal life a lot
i get i get a lot of attacks uh online
on social media uh from people
um you know whenever i you know
say something about politics or about
religion or what have you so two very
safe topics of conversation
and my guest joel stein
has written actually an entire book on
this subject called in defense of
elitism why i'm better than you and you
are better than someone who didn't buy
this book joel stein if you don't know
him is just an absolute national
treasure
he is a
very funny writer he began his
career
writing and and researching for uh
martha stewart living uh and then got
fired by martha stewart i believe she
fired him twice in the same day uh
and then uh began working for timeout
new york eventually joined time magazine
where he did
uh that final column if you remember
there were these things that we used to
have called magazines and you would like
you know go to a store and buy them and
stuff and then they were like you would
like physically
handle them you would hold them and like
flip through these kind of waxy pages
ask your parents anyway
for a good i don't know i want to say
20 years
uh joel wrote a column
uh in time magazine when he would spout
off about all kinds of different things
you know about the world science
politics religion arts culture
uh and so
he was
or is i should say uh about as close as
an elitist
an intellectual elitist as we could find
for the pod and we wanted to have him
come in
and answer a uh a question for us
what's so bad about being smart
joel stein thank you for
joining i was gonna say us but it's just
me on metaphysical milkshake i can't
believe you're having me on i know we're
friends and that's why but i am not of
the caliber of
of your guests and so i'm really honored
and i'm more honored that rayne isn't
here because he brings the show down and
i'd rather just talk to you he really he
does
i thought this for a very long time that
he's just basically dead weight that i
drag along with me
he's famous so i think that helps um
yeah i mean but you know i first
he was famous right exactly yeah thank
you so can i bring something up oh yeah
please please can i bring something up
first is that is that rude i'm i'm
acting this is there
okay
so i was thinking about how honored i am
honestly to be on this podcast where
peter singer has appeared yes
i interviewed him once too
but there was something you said on that
episode that greatly uh upset me
uh okay
you said
that you disagreed with his utilitarian
point of view because if you were on a
playground and you had to save one of
your 17 children you would let a
thousand kids die and save your own kid
yes
and we all know that's a
human instinct we all have
um and it's kind of one that we're a
little proud of having for various
reasons it's a show of love
but the answer to that is
what's best for
public policy what's best
philosophically what's best for the
world isn't your human instinct i mean
if we just went by our human instincts
the world would be a disaster like we're
supposed to control those through higher
thought and the higher thought is you do
not save your child for a thousand other
children that's wrong
it may feel right but it's wrong
this sounds exactly like
something an intellectual elitist prick
would say
right am i am i wrong about this joe i
mean this is that's why i'm here yeah so
it's a perfect segue uh into into our
our conversation well look the
what we're gonna talk about is
you know anti-intellectualism what's
wrong with being smart
uh this is something that you obviously
have a lot to say about not just as a
smart person but as somebody uh who has
written this incredible book which i
love it came out a little while ago in
defense of elitism
why i'm better than you and you are
better than someone who didn't buy this
book we we have actually talked at
length about this book i actually
interviewed you uh for this book uh some
years back
uh in front of a lot of old jews
it was it was so
it was so nice of you and you taught me
you taught me a lot about how to
interview people that night like i've
changed how i was just on stage
interviewing steve martin and i
remembered a lot of things you did which
was you provide so much clarity you like
explained before we started what the
book was and what the conversation was
and um
and you really made it clear to the
audience what was going on wow that kind
of makes me feel good and i really
appreciate how you managed to throw in
that you just talked to steve martin
explain to us exactly what what are we
talking about when we talk about the
elites just so we we're all on the same
page
this is literally the thing you cleared
up in front of the old jews which i i
after i talked after you did that i
realized i need to explain what i mean
by the elite all right let's see let's
see what you learned yeah what i learned
is i'm there there are two different
kinds of elite that i talked about in
the book the one i celebrate which i
call the intellectual elite
which um
which are people who rush limbaugh would
have said are in
the the four
off we call the four evil horsemen of uh
academia i forgot how he phrased it but
he said these are the these are the evil
people academia
uh media
government
uh
science oh i was the fourth
science i know it's science maybe yeah i
should look that up but um yeah so
that's the intellectual elite and then
what i call the boat elite are people
who care about
money more than ideas and care about
power more than cooperation uh they're
people who kind of believe to they
operate from their gut and they always
own boats and boat people are the worst
people in the world and there's this
fight right now between these two kinds
of elite
the worst
right like they're so awful that we've
agreed as a society if they can get 11
miles away from us they can do whatever
they want
that's right that's how they go
they love puns
they
are obsessed with puns and they put it
they write it on their boats when they
when they buy a boat they take a
a totally decent bottle of champagne and
smash it on their boat that's the first
thing they want to do
animals
trade coffee connects customers to the
freshest and best tasting coffee they've
ever made at home how do they do it they
partner with the country's best craft
roasters these are independent
businesses from big cities and small
towns trade customers are truly
impactful for these independent roasters
often being the largest source of new
growth for them
it's expert tasted coffee trades coffee
team actually taste test thousands of
coffees to keep 450 different kinds live
and ready to ship every day there's no
one perfect coffee but there is a
perfect coffee for you
whether your friends call you a coffee
snob or if you just know it when coffee
tastes really perfect trades real coffee
experts personally taste over 450 roasts
so they know exactly what to recommend
for you i've got i've got a couple of
trade coffees right here these are
my favorite ones
yeah i got this one from irving farm in
new york like there's no
way i would have ever known that this is
my new favorite coffee like where i'm
not gonna go to irving farm in new york
and get their coffee
anyway i mean it's really a pretty
awesome service and right now trade is
offering new subscribers a total of 30
off your first order plus you get free
shipping when you go to drinktrade.com
milkshake
that's more than 40 cups of coffee for
free get started by taking their quiz
it's actually a pretty fun quiz to be
honest with you at
drinktrade.com
milkshake and let trade find you a
coffee that you'll love that's
drinktrade.com
milkshake for 30 off
i i like i like the way that you that
you're constructing this so
which one are you by the way and i
haven't constructed this like uh
nietzsche constructs this um
pareto vilfredo pareto if i talk about
the book constructs this this is this is
a fight that's been going on
for centuries between these two groups
and and they'll take
you know they'll claim to represent the
people in order to
get power but it's a small group of
people who are fighting each other in
these two worlds yeah so that's that's
the thing is like this whole this whole
way in which these elites kind of claim
to be populists right
what exactly what's the difference
between an elitist and a populist just
so we all understand
so
in the book i i
kind of narrow down to
these four groups but one of them
is the um
is the elite who are kind of pretending
not to be elites yeah they're populist
elites politicians and in
there there there could be politicians
they could be rush limbaugh they could
be on the me they could be
the media they could be tucker carlson
lots of people but they're
yeah yeah i think elon musk is a great
example but there are people
who come from the intellectual elite
they've probably gone to some ivy league
or equivalent school
um
and they
they claim
and
they have a legitimate
philosophy about life which is a very
tribal
um roman
honor culture
uh
zero sum power view this tony soprano's
kind of view of how the world works
which they believe
like a putin
believes or a trump
that they are
honest because the world is corrupt and
will always be corrupt and they are
going to they see that and they're not
naive and they're going to go out and
kick ass for you the real people there's
always a real people involved in
populism and some people don't count as
the real people because they're not part
of your tribe because this is a tribal
way of looking at things and other
people are part of your tribe and and an
orange and they should be
at least excluded if not attacked
it's instinctually correct right like
it's how we all think and operate
without giving it too much thought so
it's like you saving your kid
at the expense of a thousand children is
instinctually right when sarah palin
talks about like i know in my gut
what's right and all these politicians
and lawyers try and make it complicated
so they can get what they want and skim
off the top but in the end you don't
need to know anything more than what's
right or wrong to run the free world
and there's a part of us
that just
instinctually feels that's right does it
also have to do with
the sort of ways that we can undermine
people with power
and people with privilege i mean it
feels like so much of
anti-intellectualism
is
predicated on
um you know trying to
halt the acquisition of any kind of new
knowledge
specifically as a way to undermine those
groups that have power those groups that
have privilege by sort of painting these
ideas as uh irrelevant to daily life you
know or or just or just flat out wrong
yeah i think newness
is scary i think a lot of the
populist movement we're seeing
everywhere
people talk about race so much but i
think it's actually more about gender
and kind of switching
or changing roles of
gender i mean there's so much change
going on that picking out one thing like
race or gender or technology it's all
mixed together and making people or
globalism and immigration it's all
making people freaked out but also to
take some blame i have an extremely
punchable face as you know and so i
think said that many times
well you've you've moved to punch me
more than once and that's not unusual
so there's something about
having knowledge that can make people
really smug
in a really
hateable way that just makes you
want to get rid of them
yeah i mean look everybody knows that
but i think the flip side of it is that
what is it about someone being smart and
someone expressing
their intelligence
that
that sort of feels threatening to to
people and we did we talked about you
know that it does give you this kind of
sense of powerlessness right that there
is something to that
um
that it's uh you know
anti-intellectualism is a way of
sort of uh pushing back uh against
uh privilege you know and and the power
of others uh but
there's something about
intellectualism
smartness if you will that just kind of
for a large swath of of the population
makes them
feel defensive and makes them feel
like they want to reach out and and
punch
you know joel stein
can you talk about that a little bit
like what what is the threat that people
feel by that
i don't know i feel it right whenever
someone tells me i'm wrong about
something especially if it's like a
decently
held belief but even if it's not it's
just something i think
like my gut reaction my instinct is to
tell them they're wrong and to push that
idea away and
it's just
just it's just work it's just change
to want to change your mind is a lot of
work
i think that's part of it i think
there's a lot of insecurity
about this huge complicated world
and a need to feel like to simplify it
in some way into a zero-sum game
everyone thinks that every other
industry that they're not in
is can be solved by some simple idea
they have but as soon as someone like
makes their industry sound simple
they're like whoa there's a lot more
going on than what i do and there's
because they understand the complexity
and what they do but not what anyone
else does i call it in my book the
meteorologist fallacy yeah yeah i was
just gonna ask you about that talk about
that a little bit
meteorologists have gotten really
much much better over time like it used
to be they were accurate within uh
three days they're now really accurate
within five days
but everyone's always saying how their
weatherman can't be trusted and they get
it wrong all the time
and
and it's like yeah weather is an
insanely complicated thing like the fact
that we're able to predict the weather
at all is a miracle of science but
people
are just doctors people are always like
my doctor didn't know what was wrong
with me i'm like yeah you know what they
used to do not long ago they used to try
and balance your humors like it's really
impressive what they know now but they
don't know everything and there's this
entitled expectation that like if you
get get it wrong once you never know
it's like with elections right with
polling if it's a little bit wrong
or i don't know i watch a decent amount
of baseball and now when i do it online
they tell you the percentage likelihood
of winning
which is insane right because
you watch enough baseball games you have
a 90-something percent chance of winning
by the eighth inning and then something
happens because you're watching enough
baseball games where something's going
to happen sometimes and it just you're
my brain's not able to do the math of
this happens once out of every you know
10 15 games it just seems insane that my
team had a 92 chance of winning and they
lost
and this meteorologist
fallacy we find it
in everything right like if if the if
the government was incorrect in how long
you know it was going to take
afghanistan to collapse
then the entire entire intelligence
uh apparatus is all [ __ ] um if yeah you
know the scientists uh
screwed up their predictions about you
know how bad covet was going to be or
whether this particular mask was going
to work as well as this particular mask
well then there are wrong so then [ __ ]
them they don't know anything
and anything any scientist says now we
can just simply ignore it runs the gamut
it's just a weird expectation that if
you have a job you know a thousand
percent of everything that's ever going
to happen and everything that is
happening it's just like we're we're not
at that level yet as humans
does this seem to be i'm not going to
say it's a uniquely american phenomenon
because we obviously are seeing you know
signs of this in large parts of the
world but there is something
quintessentially american about it kurt
anderson's fantasyland makes this great
argument that i disagreed with before i
read it and agree with now which is yes
america
is uh was founded by and has been
attracting some hardcore true believers
of all stripes of basically the taliban
of every religion comes here and uh
and yeah i think we are
we are a huckster nation
but but but
maybe i i still think it's by
percentages other countries have this
they do but but but we we i feel like
it's more pronounced here and maybe it's
because of kind of what what kurt
anderson was saying i was actually
thinking of richard hofstadter
but one of the things that hofstadter
says
is that
you know it
that it is it is fundamentally part of
our american
identity you know that it's
it's part of our national um
uh sense of who we are as americans and
it does kind of
go back a little bit to the founding
fathers right i mean
ben franklin george washington
uh these were
guys who constantly talked about
you know the self-made man in opposition
to like the enlightened
intellectuals and you know they they
they created this mythology of like the
american as a kind of rugged
industrialist you know who who started
with nothing and through hard work
became you know the the captain of
industry
when in reality these were like
wealthy intellectual
you know slave-ownering
uh elites
you know this this is from the beginning
this is this has been part of our
identity i feel like the founders were
more
steeped in the enlightenment and were
pretty pro-intellectual whereas the uh
the
the puritans obviously believe some
crazy stuff uh i need but yeah we we uh
we are the guys who develop snake oil
we're the guys you know we did a lot of
that kind of work of saying don't trust
the
intellectual certainly jackson uh andrew
jackson was a big part of that um
you know opening up the white house
even even on his uh
his inauguration party was open to the
public and they trashed the white house
and then he
someone gave him a gift of like a a
round of cheese that was so large he
stored it in his closet and it just
stunk up the white house like
um there was a big push against those
original founding fathers like when john
quinciano's loses to jackson it was um
oh the the
what was it you could either have
someone who's
smart or knows how to fight like that
was that it was if it rhymed so i'm
getting it wrong but that was the the
argument john quincy adams had and when
jackson won everyone just like packed up
their bags like this country
it's over
kind of like when trump won right like
that's the feeling i had i was gonna say
that sounds kind of familiar i'm sure
i'm sure that the biden folks found like
a giant wheel of cheese in a closet
somewhere
in the oval office no you think he eats
cheese
it's just kfc and
mcdonald's well i guess there's cheese
in those things sometimes yeah it's a
bucket of chicken somewhere underneath
the
the resolute desk um
but i mean again i think you know going
from jackson to
um
uh
trump
it's just you know further proof that
this this kind of strain of
anti-intellectualism has been part of
the american identity for for a really
really long time
isaac asimov has this really great line
um
where
he once wrote the strain of
anti-intellectualism has been nurtured
by the false notion that democracy means
that my ignorance is just as good as
your knowledge
so maybe that's what it is maybe it's
it's that sort of concept of you know
one person one vote that we're all we're
all supposed to be equal somehow means
that
you know ignorance and knowledge are
that have that they have equal value in
society
that's exactly kind of what got me
working on this i started
when sarah palin was nominated as vice
president she started saying things that
really scared me and that's when i
started writing about this in time and
that led to this book but yeah she was
saying
pretty overtly that like i my gut is
more pure and more right
than than anyone's knowledge so
therefore i'm more capable of dealing
with russia
and i'm more capa even though i don't
know where these countries are who the
leaders are i know right from wrong
and and that makes me superior and then
around the same time joe biden was
when joe biden was vice president
that some i forgot he was sotomayor
somebody was uh nominated for the
supreme court and matt lauer
was on the today show interviewing joe
biden about it like you he was like
basically if you this woman gets on the
supreme court it'll be nine people who
went to ivy league schools
like
how how is that representative of our
country
and so joe biden immediately was like i
went to syracuse and i was like what all
right we're having a contest to see who
this is this is an incredibly
intellectual pursuit if we were to pick
one thing it's like how come all your
physics professors went to college i'm
like it's the supreme court we can we
get a pass at least for that on being an
intellectual but everyone was
everyone has to now be and it happened
actually when nixon was president there
was this guy
uh
aruska who was nominated i think he did
not pass the senate but his defense
for not being that smart was like don't
don't not smart people deserve a
representative on the court
and i thought that sort of drives me
crazy well so this you bring up a really
good point because i think sometimes we
think of
anti-intellectualism as being you know
primarily something that you see on the
right but no you you you argue that you
see it just as much on the left as on
the right in what ways do you see it on
the left oh it's the same it it
horseshoes around a bit on corruption
that that it's the same idea that the
there's um
some
people who know who
maybe are too intellectual aren't
representing the common man because they
don't have the
the work experience and they are they're
kind of corrupt and lawyerly and keeping
it to themselves i mean i i guess what
i'm talking about is
is it the same kind of derision toward
uh education and knowledge like bernie
sanders has that that economist who
works with him who believes in
it's a belief that interest rates don't
matter right and it's this kind of
radical rethinking of economics
that's very far left but also
is kind of just wishful thinking and and
um and that's the kind of stuff that
kind of
on the left bothers me that it's like
all these economists are kind of corrupt
and they're all from the same schools
and they all believe the same things and
the thing is like sometimes that's true
sometimes a bunch of people believe
something and there's an outsider with
an idea and it's the right idea and then
everyone re everyone readjusts right but
that's not
that's not the common way that that
knowledge gets
increased usually it's someone very much
from the inside who has an idea
but but we have this love of the idea of
the other
the kid with a telescope who discovers
pluto
um but that's not usually how it goes
i guess i was thinking uh more sort of
about the way in which you get
you know the kind of anti-vaccine
uh movements
and on the right oh robert kennedy
yeah or like or santa monica you know
you go to you go to santa monica over
here in l.a and it's like
half the population is is unvaxed
because that's part of it right it's
this idea that like well i know more i
know more than the doctors do i know
more than the scientists do and on the
right it's you know we laugh at it
because
you know the the person's like you know
i did my own research and i know that
you know it's bill gates is trying to
get you with the vaccine and you're like
well that's just stuff that's the accent
the right talking yeah yeah yeah exactly
thank you that's exactly the
the punchable face part of this whole
conversation
but on the then you get it on the left
with people who you know in other parts
of their lives seem to be very fairly
rational and and maybe even
well-educated but the
exact same argument
i've been to the goop convention in new
york city for two days um
and the stuff that they the amount of
detoxifying it turns out your body needs
until about five o'clock when you drink
at the goop convention putting like the
worst toxin known to manage your body um
or one of them no yeah so did you go
through this i went through this when we
had uh
well you must have gone through this 12
or 13 times with all the children you
have that's true but i um first
encountered this
we had this doctor
this pediatrician in this adorable cute
little house right near us
and he was a great great guy
turns out he was heidi fleisch's father
but he'd been practicing for
decades in la
but it turned out he and his partner who
had since moved to santa monica did not
believe that aids was caused by the hiv
virus they were so far left right and i
was like i don't think i want my son
going to a doctor who's got
beliefs in science that aren't true and
then my lovely wife cassandra was a
little concerned about giving our baby
all of these vaccines you know this is
this is he's 13 now this is long before
covet and so i was very upset by this
just like i'm very upset by what gmos is
another crazy thing left was worried
about so i brought out she's got me to
agree i think we paid
to go to some kind of auditorium and
listen to like
some anti-vaxx lady
a lady is the is the most sexist thing i
could add on to this um person of some
gender i don't remember and so we go uh
listen to this person
and uh
they
are spouting nonsense and i'm a i don't
get very emotional
and so i
raised my hand to ask a question
because this has been the specific
question that come up between cassandra
and i and i said
if we um put off the hepatitis vaccine
for our son
and he gets bit on the playground by a
kid who has hepatitis
um is that is that a way that kids
can
get it
um
and she said
um
i see way more cases of people that get
i don't know some crazy disease scurvy
or rickets or something from getting the
vaccine than i do from kids who catch
hepatitis
i was like okay that's not my question
my question is is it possible if he gets
bit he would get hepatitis and she said
something super dismissive which was
like if that's a worry for you then go
ahead and do it i'm like not asking
about my worries i'm just asking about
the science of it like is that a way
and she dismissed me again with like if
you're gonna be worried about that then
then you know
and i
walked out like i stormed out like it
was an awful movie with cassandra and um
and then we got our son we spaced them
out a tiny bit but we basically got him
vaccinated but
i have very smart friends who are very
far left who do not get their kids
vaccinated
is that this kind of human impulse to
say
my gut like you were saying my gut is
right and i don't care you know what
your your brain says i i only listen to
my gut my gut is right
and i'm going to go do my own research
do you want my own research which by the
way
that for that phrase
you know
sounds like you're in
sounds like you're in a lab somewhere
doing some real science right you're
googling right
research you're doing stuff you wouldn't
even count as research for your book you
were writing no less doing your own
research no no
joe joe rogan doesn't have a lab coat on
he's not like
looking through a microscope doing his
own research it means like he's not even
yeah yeah no but but but
in in that case it's just it's funny
because
you know this idea that that so much of
anti-intellectualism has to do with the
feeling of powerlessness you know which
i which i think is right
and
this feeling of
you know oh uh
you think you're better than me because
you're more educated than me but when we
see it on the left when we see it you
know amongst very highly educated people
it kind of
pokes holes in that theory a little bit
and it becomes a little bit more about
this
like we you were just saying a little
while ago this kind of human impulse to
um
to give a kind of shape to your fears
right to talk about it as intuition
instead of intelligence
yeah what bothers me is that
we have this insanely impressive society
that we have no appreciation for we just
sit around talking about how the weather
people the meteorologists suck and our
doctor doesn't know what i have and like
i wish we just all had to go on a time
machine to any other time period and
just were in wonder about what we have
and like the fact that people
worked to create this and instead
we just seem to see the problems in it
and think it's all corrupt and that
people
just
the assumption that everyone is doing
everything for monetary gain is so
messed up
like i know there's a lot of people who
are that way and think everyone else is
that way
but
it's just not true like if you've
interviewed politicians
you may not agree with them
but they're not all corrupt and doing
things because the nra gave them money
like they really are dedicating their
lives to at least in their own head
improving the world like maybe they like
power maybe they you know there are
other things that drive them but it's
the idea that they're all corrupt is so
screwed up the best is the best is when
you hear this about like scientists or
something all those guys on the cdc
they're just you know they're just in it
for the money
because that's exactly
what that that poor nerd at the cdc is
thinking to himself i'm gonna make up
some lies about a vaccine cause that's
gonna make me rich
anthony fauci waited 70 years
plotted and planned
to finally get his way in working with
bill gates yeah but used but i see it
like i live in this super liberal part
of la and i see like [ __ ] fouchy or bill
gates is in your brain or i see these
like um
graffiti everywhere
yeah
as uh as rain i think has said a couple
of times on this podcast like
we already have a chip embedded in our
brains that follows us everywhere and
knows exactly what we're thinking it's
your [ __ ] phone yeah so we already
have that
and by the way there's a million buttons
you can press to at least improve the
data privacy of your phone that you have
not bothered pressing
as you worry about the vaccine that
would take like minutes
um and i've done my own research so
reign must believe in some crazy
left-wing stuff that's anti-science
for sure yeah he's uh he's totally uh
anti-vaxxer flat earther
um
he's no i don't okay we can't
i will i can't i can't spill my uh my
co-host's uh secrets when he's not here
look if he doesn't show up he doesn't
show up yeah but this is this is an
important point because you know
we're laughing about this and you know
we're making fun of people because
that's what we do as intellectuals we
make fun of other people um
but how concerned should we be
you know about
the rise of anti-intellectualism today
so much more concerned than we are
and
people forget that like progress is not
linear that the
the dark ages middle ages whatever we
call them now
lasted a long time there was a long time
in which
humans on the planet couldn't do what
their great-great-grandfathers could do
like literally couldn't make the tools
the the information had been lost i mean
elon musk is insane but when he talks
about needing to go to mars while we
still have the abili the knowledge to
get there this is what he's talking
about i mean maybe talking about nuclear
war but
but societies it's not pure progress
people go backwards people make very bad
choices um
and and certainly we can think about
societies
you know not the middle ages but more
recently like cambodia that just got rid
of all their intellectuals you know took
off if you had glasses they just shot
you and put you in a pit
if you could read they killed you i mean
they set their society back
who knows how long you know generations
worth that's that society's not going to
catch up for a long time so yeah we
should be super worried yeah
and by the way when you get these like
when you get governments that are
anti-intellectual and tribal and are are
both elite
the odds of going to war really increase
but i'm just thinking putin is a great
example of what happens when you get
those kind of people they sure
if you have a zero-sum game you're like
let's invade crimea to invade ukraine
let's buy greenland like you have a very
simple notion of
of the world being like risk
right the board game
in the process of writing this book you
you know traveled around the country and
you met with a lot of you know different
people a lot a lot of trumpers uh
uh a lot of the kind of
anti-intellectuals uh
you know mostly on the right but you
know some on the left is as well
uh you went to a you know a town
that was basically like 98 trump voters
and kind of
got to know them i think you were the
first jew that they ever met you may
have been the first jew that ever
stepped foot in the town actually no
that was the weird thing about this town
it was the county with the highest
percentage of trump voters in 2016 in
the country that's why i went to this uh
county
but um
they knew so much more about me than i
knew about them because they watch tv
and movies and they all seemed to know
some
someone knew like uh
was it went to college with some jewish
person that worked at like
some food website in manhattan and yeah
they knew they knew jews they
jewish teacher in the school in that
town at some point so they all they
started singing the dreidel song to me
at some point it was bizarre
because my mom and and like my dad and
everyone
were really they got me really scared
before i left like i thought i was
really nervous like super nervous about
going to this town like for my safety
and they all told me not to tell anyone
i was jewish that was the first thing
even my non-jewish friends were like
just don't tell them you're a jew well
with a name like joel stein you could be
anything obviously i mean yeah exactly
yeah
you know i just i you would have been in
some trouble there
yes i
i would have although i can talk jesus
pretty well so like well you know once
you can talk to jesus and get in easily
i went to church with them there was a
lot of jesus talk
um i thought that's what you were going
to say why they knew about jews they're
like oh yeah they knew about jews like
jesus
um
you also met with the the dilbert
cartoonist scott adams and i and the
only reason i want to bring this part up
is because you know this about me i
[ __ ] hate scott adams i
loathe that man you would love him in
person
i'm serious the way that he comes off in
in your book is exactly the the
douchebagginess that i would assume from
him this kind of
ridiculously rich who did you hate more
in my book scott adams or tucker carlson
two people like after talking to
amazing okay
yeah for sure what do you hate so much
about scott adams
yeah i mean and if i saw if i was
driving you know down a dark road and i
saw tucker carlson in front of me i
would speed up and i hate scott adams
more
uh
because that tucker tucker
tucker is playing a [ __ ] role okay
tucker swanson is just that that's just
a a persona on television
uh but i don't know what scott adams
would you call him tucker swanson
because his uh he comes from swanson
dinner money like his stepmom is the
swanson is that right yes that's right
yes but so tell me uh tell me why your
hatred of uh scott adams is so intense
because this douchebag this is for
everyone this is the guy who is the
creator of dilbert the cartoonist to
grady gilbert and still does delbert
yeah but he goes on fox news a lot and
talks yeah any any from his perch as a
multi multi you know millionaire who
you know lives in a in a mansion cut off
from you know the the worries of of the
world he espouses this like [ __ ]
primordial manhood
uh that you know that
has as its core this idea that you know
his own
beliefs right just the power of his
beliefs because
uh primarily because of his wealth you
get this a lot with with like people
like elon musk and people like you know
donald trump you know it's like you're
rich so therefore you're better you know
more simply because you did something
that made you money in this case drew a
[ __ ] cartoon um
but that
because of that his beliefs are just
more valuable
than any kind of gained knowledge right
any kind of
just just by definition the fact that
you gained your knowledge
uh
is is suspect
in some way and so
you know he's he espouses these ideas
these policies that
are actually you know not better for for
the the kind of people that he insists
that he is you know championing which of
which he does not belong like he's not
part of that group that he's championing
and he just to me represents
and and and i would definitely put elon
musk in this category i would definitely
put like a jeff bezos in this category i
would definitely put peter
in this category you know these like
sort of like the the the the pantheon of
douche baggery
um
that uh
that
you know espouses this view
that because they have been you know
monetarily successful
that
they their ideas about the way that the
world
should work
uh
are better than people who have actually
spent their lives focusing on those
issues and gaining the knowledge and the
education and the intellect necessary to
actually affect real change i think
that's that's what just crawls under my
skin about this guy
so one of the ways i define the
intellectual elite versus the boat elite
is that i forgot how i phrased it but
if you were given the option between a
free boat or a ted talk
you would definitely choose the ted talk
right like if you could give a ted a
really good ted talk you'd much rather
do that than have a yacht
you mean if i if i was if able to give
the ted talk
oh yeah yeah no you would give a great
ted talk yeah yeah no you don't want to
go to a teddy bear no [ __ ] that i'd like
to go to a ted talk no you're not going
to watch someone else talk no you're
going to give a ted talk that's that's
really well received way better than a
yacht or own a yacht yes i would choose
the ted talk yeah
why do you know someone you can help me
get out because i would be really
i'm just kidding go ahead
how many ted talks have you given
uh one by one by myself and uh and then
i gave uh i gave a couples ted talk just
my wife and i saw that yeah gave a ted
talk yeah yeah that might be
that might be four yachts worth a
couple's ted talk
power couple ted talks
that's pretty impressive yeah
i'm curious i'm curious how the the the
writing of this book changed your views
on
the the sort of anti-intellectual um
fervor in america and or did it did it
change issues did it make you think
differently about it
it made me it did change my views it um
made me less scared of the right as
human beings not less scared of their
policies
but i think
as people they weren't as backwards
looking as i
feared
and as angry as i feared
um
it
also put this thing in my head which
you're not gonna like
which i have since called the
republicans are right about everything
and it just made me
rethink
lots of things that these people said to
me i outright rejected and had been
outright rejecting for decades
things such as
the new york times is biased
right
and
i know having worked at time magazine
forever time magazine's bias and i would
always say yes everyone i work with is
liberal sometimes we make story choices
that we shouldn't because those are the
things we're knowledgeable about and
interested
but in general we are really good at
keeping bias out of our stories
i don't think that the little i watch of
cnn and the lot i read at the new york
times i just don't think that's remotely
true anymore i think they were right and
i can say and there's about 10 things
that i've kind of opened my mind up
about what else tell me more because
this is fascinating
i keep i'm afraid to write this piece
right yeah but um because my friends are
gonna be so angry um
what else
oh i think
i think there's a lot of people on the
left that throw out
racism as an attack
um
when it's not necessarily either true or
warranted and it's just a useful
um
it's just a useful attack more than an
insightful
truth
i think that happens a lot
for instance like the the right used to
talk about
how cities are being overrun
with homeless people and crime
and
uh i remember i was once at this
i was at politicon doing something and
james carville and sean hannity were
debating
and carving was getting crushed because
hannity is a professional debater like
that's all he does all day
and at some point hannity was talking
about how san francisco is a horrible
place to live and carvel had this
amazing comeback which was he's like
you're totally right
nobody wants to live there
it's so cheap to get an apartment
like you know uh you're totally right in
san francisco however like you know from
living in l.a
i argued against
you know the poli
the the problems we've
caused and and societies caused in
cities are real i think everyone's
acknowledged that than that they didn't
maybe six years ago
is this all your way i have a little
list in my head is this all your way of
admitting that you are now an
anti-elitist
no no i believe this that's the thing i
believe the solutions to all these
problems
are intellectual solutions and they're
and in fact the resistance to the
solutions first of all these problems
are highly complex so there's not one
solution i'm not i don't want to
advocate some simplistic version of how
these problems are solved
but
the pushback against some of these
solutions which is like one of them has
built a lot more housing
um
you get you get a pushback that's very
anti-intellectual which is like
you know people just don't like housing
in their area
is there i mean this is kind of the the
last question i have i guess on this
topic but i'm just curious if you think
that there is
any way
to push back on
you know what is as you rightly say an
extremely dangerous
uh trend in american politics in
american society uh especially for us
intellectuals like you know or should we
just
um
you know
learn how to
do defensive fighting skills uh and be
ready for the end that's that's coming
around the corner we will lose that
fight like there's no fight the
intellectuals will be
the uh the bodily at that's physical
like we should just that's not in the
playbook just run just like with any any
kind of violence we should always run
um
in the in the
original version of my book which is
did they do this to you for the
paperback make you write extra chapters
yeah yeah for free right for free yeah
they're like i think i think you need a
new introduction and maybe a new final
chapter and i was like that usually
costs money but all right
we gotta unionize this is a new this
didn't happen with my first book this is
a new thing anyway they bullied me into
doing that so that my original book
ended with a
really unsatisfying
answer question which is we should be
less smug and people will listen to us
more
which is not completely
which is not completely untrue it's a
decent strategy but i have a sl i don't
have a very satisfying answer at the end
of the paperback but slightly better
which is i think
we failed to tell
a compelling story of globalism
so
religions told a very compelling story
that banded large groups of people
together
nations told a really compelling story
that banded people together i don't i
mean the best we've had to ban the globe
together was like
uh john lennon's imagine
or like when coca-cola wanted us to
teach the world to sing and that by the
way those were both like 50 years ago
and they both sort of were simplistic
drivel but i think we need a real story
that that connects
the globe and how cooperation
because globalism which neoliberal
globalism
has
been such an improvement for the planet
if you look at
rates of
of extreme poverty and all the horrors
that come with that i mean we've we just
saved so many people just by just
through globalism just through through
international trade and through um you
know being able to move information
around the world so i think there's a is
a compelling version of that story that
we think of ourselves as a planet
instead of a country or
i don't know like
whatever tribes we're now kind of
devolving into
i don't know that story you know on the
one hand that's actually a a pretty
satisfying answer on the other hand we
have a rule that whenever someone brings
up neo-liberal globalism
the interview's over so that's the
that's all the time we have for you now
uh joel stein that's that's a good rule
is that raymond's rule
it's my rule
when i guess brings up neoliberal
globalism that's it conversation's done
uh joel stein this has been so
fascinating thank you so much for uh for
you know coming on with your smug
punchable face and
explaining why you're so smart and
everybody else is dumb because they
uh listen to their gut instead of your
intellect i really appreciate that when
rain calls you tonight and says what did
i miss what did they miss what are you
gonna tell them i'm gonna say nothing
that's exact
that's about right you missed nothing
uh the book is now in paperback it's
called in defense of elitism it's very
very funny and very enlightening
joel stein thanks for uh for joining us
on the milkshake yeah and i just want to
say when a humor writer writes a book
about politics things are bad
i don't know if it's going to get much
worse but i hear that
i hope not i want to go back to writing
about my penis
wow that was a great conversation it
sure was reza i agree rain i thought
that that was really good i thought i
would say better than our usual episodes
oh yeah i just i just make things worse
i think i thank you for saying that rain
i i didn't want to say it but i'm i'm
really glad that you didn't and also you
know your voice it sounds very authentic
uh this particular episode yeah thanks
very much reza
uh
i'll just go ahead and close this out
here folks if you want more of life's uh
big questions it's very easy you can
find us on social media at reza aslan at
rainwilson
we're on twitter at metamilkpodcast and
on instagram
metaphysicalmilkshake uh let us know
your life's big question we just might
explore them on a future episode and
remember to follow rated review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
or wherever you listen to podcasts
that's true rain thank you for that uh
and also don't forget that you can also
subscribe to the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel and watch our full
episodes every week see you next week
everybody see you rain
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa de yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
kurt does such a great job it's a fun
read it's basically the history of
america through hucksters and hey guys
why can we can we just get kurt instead
well rain will come on if kurt's here
rain will 100 be here if kurt's on
we've already we've already run the tape
so we're gonna have to just go with you
joel go ahead
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you